Dr Zaretsky didn’t remember falling.
She’d hit her head on impact with the ground,
hard enough to knock the immediate memory
out of her brain.
But not quite hard enough to remember everything
else.
The feeling of mushy fungal fingers wrapping
around her waist, of rising rapidly into the
air, the haze of deadly spores so thick in
the air that they’d created a layer coating
her hazmat suit.
5 meters.
That’s how far she’d fallen.
About half the height of an Olympic diving
board.
Only there wasn’t a pool at the bottom.
And she’d landed badly.
Dr Zaretsky had been lying in her hospital
bed for nearly a month.
It was rare to have an encounter with a 30-meter-tall
SCP go south and still live to tell the tale.
She knew that as well as anyone, seeing colleagues
dying in all kinds of ways around her for
years.
But try as she might, through all the broken
bones, all the bruises and scars, and all
the indignity that being bedridden in a hospital
brought, she couldn’t help but just feel
sad.
Were all these SCPs monsters?
And what was happening to 5771 as she lay
there broken?
*
It will be no surprise to many that the SCP
Foundation monitors emergency service calls.
Often if there is a deadly creature on the
loose, the first people to hear about it are
emergency service operators.
Whether they believe it is another case, something
that benefits the Foundation greatly much
of the time.
That was how SCP-5771 was discovered.
Bryce Wheeler, a junior agent not yet ready
for field work, was monitoring incoming 911
calls in California when a call pricked her
interest.
It wasn’t so much the content of the call
itself.
It was the fact that it was the third call
that morning where someone had died on the
phone.
As soon as the line connected, all that could
be heard were wheezing and choking noises.
The operator tried their best to reassure
the person that help was on its way, and they
were tracking the location of the call, but
it seemed to provide little comfort.
The choking noises stopped, and there was
the familiar static thud of the phone and
body falling to the ground.
Then the line just sat open, totally silent.
It made sense why the line was silent, as
Agent Wheeler looked at the tracking data
on where that call was coming from.
It was a National Park; the middle of nowhere.
Chances were there wouldn’t be any emergency
services on the scene for a good hour at least.
That gave the Foundation time to swing into
action, diverting any emergency services in
the area to other calls and creating sufficient
confusion within the emergency services to
file a couple of false response IDs so nobody
would ever notice.
That kind of thing was and is very standard
procedure for the Foundation at this point.
Since Wheeler had caught the call, she was
given permission to ride along as they went
to investigate.
She only had one piece of intel to pass on
to the senior agents as their SUV bumped its
way through the National Park, a choked word
that all three callers had said: ‘Mushroom’.
They stopped about a kilometer out from where
the call had come in from and got out of the
car to see their first body of the day.
There would be plenty more before the sun
would go down that night.
It was a hiker, early twenties, in good shape.
They’d evidently collapsed on the trail.
Lying face down, there was a small drying
pool of saliva in the dirt.
Must have been coughing too.
Agent Wheeler was just about to go over to
the body and roll it onto its back when one
of the other agents put a hand on her shoulder.
This was potentially a biohazard situation.
They could not risk getting infected.
They’d proceed in the vehicle with caution.
They passed three more bodies on the trail
as they went.
They reported each one back to the Foundation,
who were in the process of setting up a perimeter
around the National Park and combing the outskirts
looking for hikers for apprehension and medical
help.
Once they’d passed their fifth body, the
driver stopped the car again.
He was leaning forwards in his seat, peering
up into the sky.
Agent Wheeler tried her best to see what he
and all the others were looking up at but
couldn’t make it out.
They were next to a little rocky canyon with
a few trees sticking up out of the ground,
most of them stripped nearly white by the
heat of the sun.
Actually, there was one tree that looked taller
than the others.
Thinner too.
As she leaned forward in the seat and her
eyes saw more and more of the tree, she quickly
realized it wasn’t a tree at all.
It was a pair of spindly legs, then a skeletal
torso with gangly arms, then an elongated
neck, and then… a mushroom.
Without thinking, Agent Wheeler opened the
SUV’s door and stepped out into the California
heat.
She was tiny in comparison to the creature
before her, barely as tall as its ankle.
Its whole body seemed to be soft and slightly
wrinkled, just like the mushrooms you’d
cook with at home.
Her mouth fell wide open as she stared up
at it, and to her surprise, it turned around
and stared back.
It didn’t have eyes, a face, or any features
at all.
All there was was a giant mushroom for a head,
but somehow it seemed to ‘see’ her.
It leaned down and peered closely at her.
The agents in the car were yelling something
behind her, but she ignored them.
There was something ancient about this creature
and yet something so young and innocent.
She coughed.
Then coughed again.
Tiny spores were floating through the air
all around her.
Within three minutes, Agent Wheeler’s throat
had totally closed off, full of fungal growths.
The other agents tried to open fire on the
creature but were all dead just moments after
she was, all choked to death.
*
All told, the Foundation discovered 18 civilian
bodies that day.
Each was reported to their family as having
died of other causes.
No autopsies were allowed to be carried out.
Anyone who claimed to have seen any kinds
of mushrooms when interrogated that day were
administered Class-A amnestics
The containment perimeter quickly tightened
as Foundation personnel moved in on this enormous
Mushroom Man.
With heavy weaponry at the ready, the Foundation
surrounded the creature.
It bent down on its approach with hands out
by its sides.
This was interpreted as an act of hostility,
and the SCP was secured swiftly and without
leniency.
A special containment cell had to be constructed
for the Mushroom Man as it was far too tall
for any standard cell.
It was detained in an external holding area
until the 32-meter tall cell had completed
construction.
Once inside, the Foundation was able to get
to work studying it.
Designated SCP-5771, this SCP measures 30.48
meters in height.
Its organic tissue seems to be made up entirely
of a gargantuan fungal growth.
The ‘head’ of the creature resembles a
mushroom of the Amanita pantherina species,
also known as the Panther Cap mushroom.
The body resembles a rudimentary humanoid
skeleton.
Samples taken from it have revealed that it
is composed of the mushroom’s stalk material,
while the creature’s thorax is made up of
the ring of the fungus.
It has a keen awareness of external stimuli,
particularly living beings.
A mouse in a cage was placed inside its cell
for one hour.
Unlike all of the humans exposed to 5771’s
spores, the mouse did not die or suffer any
form of fungal infection.
What was more notable, however, was 5771’s
response to the mouse.
Leaning in as close as it could, it appeared
to stare at the mouse for the entire time
that the mouse was in its cell, despite lacking
eyes or any obvious sensory organs.
Researchers noted an apparent air of curiosity
about the tiny creature, or at the very least,
a primitive interest.
5771 emits spores continuously.
When it moved into its holding cell, the room
filled with so many spores over the course
of the week that it was difficult to even
observe the creature through the cameras.
It was determined that the cell would have
to be cleaned twice a week.
To ascertain how safe this would be, D-2304
was sent into the cell in a level 2 hazmat
suit.
Within three minutes, the D-class personnel
was dead.
It was decided that level 4 hazmat suits were
required, and since then, there have been
no issues with infections of personnel from
the spores.
This is where Dr. Zaretsky came in.
A keen Mycologist with a background in studying
the cordyceps genus, she had leaped at the
opportunity to study SCP-5771.
A particular breakthrough came when communication
was established with the Mushroom Man.
Dr. Zaretsky had the idea of using biodata
sonification to try to look for any microcurrent
fluctuations in SCP-5771; the same ones that
occur in non-anomalous living organisms.
To her and the research team’s surprise,
as soon as the electrodes were inserted into
the SCP’s feet, a low, slow voice seemed
to appear in the static noise of the computers.
‘Nature…is…friend…
Nature…is…friend…why?…’
Enthused by her breakthrough Dr. Zaretsky
set up an interview slot as soon as possible
to talk to 5771.
It appeared to have a limited vocabulary,
but did not display any significant difficulties
in understanding her.
When asked where it came from, 5771 simply
replied, ‘Nature’.
When asked for further specifics, it was only
able to add that it came from ‘Mother.’
Keen to understand what its purpose was, Dr.
Zaretsky changed tack, asking the mushroom
giant why it had been born.
Why was it here?
What did it want?
On the surface, it appeared to ignore the
question, choosing to ask one of its own.
‘Why… hurt… mother?’
Taken slightly aback by this, the Doctor tried
to clarify what it meant by them ‘hurting
mother.’
The creature was not referring to her specifically
but to humanity collectively.
It appeared to use the words ‘mother’
and ‘nature’ fairly interchangeably, so
Dr Zaretsky asked if it was referring to climate
change.
5771 seemed to confirm that, informing her
that ‘mother’ was hurting, asking why
humans wanted to hurt mother.
Taking the offensive, Zaretsky asked 5771
why it had hurt and killed so many people
to which it simply said, ‘unintentional…
apologies…’
It was then ascertained that the creature
has no conscious control over the release
of its deadly spores.
Later assessment has also theorized that 5771
does not bend down towards humans as an attack
to expose them to more spores, but is instead
trying to make itself less intimidating.
It spent much of the rest of the interview
asking Dr. Zaretsky for forgiveness for its
actions.
The SCP seemed very keen to let her and the
other researchers know that it never meant
to hurt anybody and even demonstrated remorse
over its actions.
In an attempt to reassure the SCP, who seemed
to be growing more distressed by the minute,
Zaretsky accepted the apology and said that
they were friends.
While it is difficult to tell if a mushroom
is joyful, researchers generally agreed that
was the displayed emotion at hearing those
words.
And perhaps that was Dr. Zaretsky’s big
mistake.
5771, so happy to have made a friend, attempted
to pick her up.
Wrapping its fungal fingers around her torso,
it lifted her straight off her feet and up
into the air.
Zaretsky screamed, taken aback completely
and overcome with the fear of suffering the
same fate as the 18 civilians in the national
park.
Realizing its mistake, the SCP dropped her
from a height of 5 meters.
She was rushed to the hospital with a broken
left wrist, fractures in her left ankle, left
arm, and left elbow, and some other minor
sprain injuries.
Out of action for two months, Dr. Zaretsky
had no contact with the SCP as she lay in
her hospital bed.
Meanwhile, 5771 grew withdrawn.
It would hunker down in the corner of its
cell in an attempt to be as unthreatening
as possible.
Equipped with a proximity alarm, Dr. Danielle
Baker took over the interview sessions.
Asking sharp, direct questions, Dr. Baker
tried to understand why SCP-5771 had attacked
her colleague.
The Mushroom Man, still crouched in the corner,
apologized profusely.
It referred to Zaretsky as ‘friend’ and
repeatedly asked where she was with growing
distress.
Dr. Baker’s interview technique in this
session led her to be reprimanded by her supervisor.
She pushed the questions hard, interrogating
the creature as to why it had hurt the Doctor.
It was only when her supervisor stepped in
that she relented, revealing that Zaretsky
was alive and recovering well.
As the interview concluded, 5771 had one request
for the departing doctor.
‘Protect… friend…’
Fortunately, none of Dr. Zaretsky’s injuries
were serious.
Within a few weeks, she was back in the cell
with 5771 conducting another interview session.
She barely entered the room and started to
talk before the SCP interrupted her with cries
of ‘friend!’ and many sincerely offered
apologies for what it had done to her.
The pair of them have conducted several interview
sessions since, many of which have been left
undocumented as they contain little relevant
data to help the Foundation understand this
SCP or the wider world.
Much of Zaretsky’s conversations with the
creature revolve around ‘Mother.’
No matter Zaretsky’s best efforts, 5771
seems unable to grasp why humans are hurting
Mother.
It uses the words ‘burned’, ‘drowned’,
‘poisoned’, and ‘tortured’ to describe
what is happening to Mother.
It claims that this is the reason that it
was created.
Discussions between Dr. Zaretsky and her wider
research team have concluded that SCP-5771
seems to have been created as a response to
the climate crisis.
Several have noted the Gaia theory as a part
of this finding, which claims that the Earth
is essentially one giant self-regulating organism,
called Gaia.
Humans, plants, and animals all play roles
equivalent to individual cells.
If one group overpopulates and begins to harm
Gaia, then the body as a whole takes steps
to address the disturbance.
SCP-5771 is theorized to be one of those steps
being taken by Gaia, Mother Earth, Nature,
or whichever title you prefer, in order to
address the problem of manmade climate change.
With the ability to empathize, communicate,
and forgive, 5771 seems to be socially capable
of encouraging behavioral changes in humans.
Others have pointed out, much to Dr. Zaretsky’s
disdain, that 5771 is also highly lethal to
humans, perhaps as a contingency measure to
control population growth.
Regardless, the Mushroom Man is to be kept
within Foundation containment indefinitely.
Interview sessions are ongoing, but it seems
unlikely that this SCP could ever be in nature
again, no matter how much Dr. Zaretsky advocates
for it.
Now check out “SCP-2800 - Cactusman” and
“SCP-504 - Bad Joke Tomatoes” for more!